you know what's a lot harder than it
seems like it should be
actually feeling alive
and what i mean by that is that we are
all constantly doing
or at least we're constantly scrolling
but we're not necessarily living
you know we keep ourselves busy to the
point of exhaustion
but we're also languishing we feel a
little bit dead inside
i think we know that on some level i
think that's part of the reason we keep
ourselves so busy and distracted to
begin with
but we don't know what to do about it
so i am here to tell you i figured out
what to do about it
we need to have more fun
so you might think that you're already
having plenty of fun and that's because
in our everyday speech we often use the
word fun to describe anything we do with
our leisure time even if it's not
actually enjoyable and in fact a waste
of time so for
so for example
we scroll through social media for fun
even though doing so often makes us feel
bad about
like kind of everything
or we'll say
that was so fun we should do that again
soon
in response
in response to things that weren't that
fun and that we don't want to do again
ever
but it's not really our fault that we're
a little bit sloppy about how we use the
word fun because even the dictionary
doesn't get it quite right you know it
says that fun is an amusement or
enjoyment or lighthearted pleasure
it's something for kids to have in play
areas
it makes it sound like it's frivolous
and optional
but if you think back on your own
memories that stand out to you as having
truly been fun and i really encourage
you to do this you know the memories
that you would describe as and forgive
me for a scientific terminology
so fun
you're going to notice that there's
something much deeper going on
i've collected thousands of these
stories from people all around the world
and i can tell you it's amazing because
when people recount
the memories in which they had the most
fun
they tell you about some of the most
joyful and treasured memories
of their lives
so in reality fun is not just
lighthearted pleasure
it's not just for kids and it is
definitely not frivolous
instead
fun is the secret to feeling alive
so today i want to propose to you a new
more precise definition of what fun is i
want to reveal some of the ways in which
it is astonishingly good for us
and i want to give you all some
suggestions for things you can do
starting right now to experience its
power for yourself
so the first thing we need to start with
um is the fact that fun is a feeling and
it's not an activity and that's
important
because a lot of times when i ask people
what's fun they'll respond with a list
of activities that they enjoy you know
they'll say dancing is fun or skiing is
fun or i don't know pickleball is fun
everyone seems to think that pickleball
is
[Laughter]
fun and sure pickleball can be fun but
we've all had experiences where
something's off and an activity that
seems like it would be fun doesn't end
up feeling fun
and then on the flip side we've had
experiences where something that doesn't
seem like it would be fun at all ends up
feeling ridiculously fun there's an
element of serendipity
but when people do have fun when they
experience this feeling it's actually
very easy to recognize because people
who are having fun
look like they're being illuminated from
within
so for example here's me and my husband
having fun together
here are some presidents having fun
together
here's archbishop desmond tutu on the
dalai lama having fun together
actually those two seem like they were
very often even constantly
having fun together
and as you can see in these photographs
true fun produces this visceral sense of
lightness and joy
it's radiant
in fact when i asked my daughter when
she was about five years old what color
fun would be
she said sunshine
so what is this sunshine you know what
is this feeling that we call fun well
when people tell me their stories about
fun it's really interesting because the
details are all different and often
quite mundane but the energy running
through them is the same and there are
three factors that are consistently
present to the point that i believe they
constitute a new definition one that is
a lot more accurate than what's in the
dictionary and those three factors are
playfulness
connection and flow
so by playfulness i do not mean you have
to play games or god forbid make believe
i just mean having a lighthearted
attitude of doing things for the sake of
doing them and not caring too much about
the outcome letting go of perfectionism
when we have fun our guard is down and
we're not taking ourselves too seriously
connection refers to the feeling of
having a special shared experience
and i do think it's possible in some
circumstances to have fun alone and for
this feeling of connection to be with
yourself or the surroundings or the
activity but in the majority of stories
that people tell me about their peak
fund memories another person is involved
and that's true even for introverts
and then flow is the state where we are
so engaged and focused on whatever we're
doing that we can even lose track of
time you can think about an athlete in
the middle of a game or like a musician
playing a piece of music it's when we're
in the zone
it's possible to be in flow and not have
fun like if you're arguing but you
cannot have fun if you are not in flow
so playfulness connection and flow all
feel great on their own but when we
experience all three at once something
magical happens
we have fun
and that doesn't just feel good it is
good for us in fact fun does so many
amazingly good things for us that i
personally believe that fun is not just
the result of human thriving it's a
cause
so for example
fun is energizing
when people tell me their stories about
fun they glow it is like a fire has been
lit inside of them and the energy and
the warmth that they give off is
contagious
you know so much of life drains us but
fun fills us
up fun also makes us present
a lot of us put a lot of work into
trying to be more present you know we do
yoga classes we meditate and that is all
great but the fact that fun is a flow
state means that when we are having fun
we simply are present there's no other
way for it to happen
fun also unites us
we live in a really polarized world and
as we all know there's a lot of very
serious problems
but when we have fun with people we
don't see them as different political
parties or nationalities or religions we
connect with them as human beings and
it's worth noting that that is the first
step in being able to work together to
solve those problems
fun also makes us healthier now being
lonely and stressed out as many of us
have been for the past two years causes
hormonal changes in our bodies that
increase our risks for disease
but when we have fun we're relaxed and
we're more socially connected both of
which have the opposite effect
so it kind of blows my mind every time i
think about it this way but having fun
is a health intervention
and then lastly fun is joyful you know
we all so desperately want to be happy
we read books about happiness we
download apps about happiness but when
we are in a moment of having fun we are
happy
so it makes me think that perhaps the
secret to long-term happiness is just to
have more everyday moments of fun
so how do we do that how do we have more
fun well to start with do not take the
suggestions you will find in magazine
articles about how to have more fun so i
looked up some of these myself and i
found suggestions that include and i'm
not making these up
roasted turkey
put together an altar to loved ones who
have passed
watch a documentary about climate change
and my personal favorite adorn your
table with gourds
so though
those are not good suggestions
instead the most effective thing you can
do to have more fun is to focus on its
ingredients by which i mean do
everything you can to fill your life
with more moments of playfulness
connection and flow
so here are some ideas for how to do so
so to start with reduce distractions in
order to increase flow
anything that distracts you is going to
kick you out of flow and prevent you
from having fun
and what's the number one source of
distraction for most of us these days
oh thank you
it's rhetorical but yes your phones
now i wrote a book called how to break
up with your phone so i have strong
feelings about this but i can guarantee
you that you are not going to have fun
if you are constantly on your phone
so today i want to challenge you to keep
your phone out of your hand as much as
possible so that you can take me up on
my second suggestion which is to
increase connection
by interacting more with other human
beings in real life
now i know
that one of the main reasons we're
constantly on our phones is specifically
to avoid having to spend time and
interact with other human beings in real
life
so i want to assure you that it is worth
it
and it is not as hard as it might seem
so here's how you do it you start by
making eye contact with someone like
look them in the eye don't look like in
the middle of their forehead where the
camera would be on a zoom call
[Laughter]
and you say hello
and if that goes well
you can introduce yourself
and if that goes well maybe you can ask
them a question maybe something that's
like thought-provoking but not overly
personal or threatening something like
what's something that fascinates you or
what's one thing that delighted you
today
you might be amazed by how good just one
little moment of connection can make you
feel
and if you do find someone to connect
with maybe ask them to join you in
trying my third suggestion which is to
increase playfulness by finding
opportunities to rebel
now i am not talking about james dean
level rebellion i'm talking about
playful deviance i'm talking about
finding ways to break the rules of
responsible adulthood and give yourself
permission
to get a kick out of your own life
so for example one person told me that
some of the most fun she'd had in recent
memory happened on a friday morning when
she and some of her friends ditched
their work and their child care
responsibilities tucked flasks into
their purses
and snuck out to a 10 30 a.m showing of
the movie bad moms
so
lastly here's one more thing that you
can do today to start having more fun
i am just kidding
prioritize it that might sound totally
obvious but one of the main reasons
we're not having enough fun is that
we're not making it a priority you know
our fund is always at the bottom of the
list and it can't speak up for itself
so i'm not suggesting that you like take
out your calendar and make an entry that
says from 4 to 6 p.m on saturday i shall
have
fun that is a guaranteed way to not have
fun
but if you know you consistently have
fun when you spend time with a
particular person make a point to spend
time with that person
if you know there's an activity that
really does often generate playful
connected flow for you carve out time
for it in your schedule
treat fun as if it is important
because it is
i've been doing this myself for a couple
of years now and it's amazing to see how
many areas of my life fun has touched
you know i'm more creative and more
productive
i'm more resilient i laugh more
making sure that i am having enough fun
has made me a better partner and better
parent
and a better friend
and it has convinced me of something
that i very much hope i can convince you
of as well
which is that my daughter
was right
fun is sunshine
it's a distillation of life's energy
and the more often we experience it the
more we will feel like we're actually
alive
thank you